The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Today, we are going
to have two topics.
In the first half we are going
to discuss visual illusions,
and in the second
half we are going
to talk about prosthetic
devices for the blind.
What I would like to
start with is, again,
to send around the
attendance sheet,
so please put your name to it.
And then, in addition,
I'm going to send
around some handouts,
one for each person.
I'm going to hand them
out in both directions.
Thank you.
The handouts we're
going to look at,
I'll refer to them
specifically as we go around.
And I also will show pretty
much the same handouts, figures
in the handouts, on the screen.
All right.
So for the first half of
the presentation today
we are going to talk
about visual illusions.
Now, the main emphasis of
what I'm going to talk about,
it'll be an attempt
to convey to you what
kinds of procedures one can use
to get a better sense of why
we see in illusions what we see.
Some of these approaches
are strictly behavioral.
And some of them have involved
experiments carried out
on a more thorough basis using
electrophysiological procedures
and so on.
But those I'm not going
to talk too much about.
But I will relate
what we can figure out
through how the
visual system works.
Now, because of that, there
are hundreds of illusions,
and I will emphasize
those that allow
us to think about why
we see what we see.
Now, one of these
illusory effects
is the so-called
Hermann grid illusion,
and that's the one
I'm going to start
with because it's a
fascinating illusion.
If you look at
this, what you see
is that at the intersections
you see sort of smudges.
And so the big question arose
as to why we see these smudges.
Now, does everybody
see those smudges?
If you look at the
handouts, I also
show you-- pay attention
only to the front page,
the one on the left, which
says the Hermann grid illusion.
So if you look at that
either on your handout
or you look at it
on the screen here,
you see these smudges at the
intersections, not where you're
looking at, but in the
smudges other than where
you're fixating.
Does everybody
see those smudges?
OK.
So the question arose why
we have these smudges.
And back in the
1960s, an investigator
came up with a
rather clever idea
of why we see these smudges.
And the person who came
up with this theory
was a fellow called Baumgartner.
And so what he proposed,
that this illusory effect
is not directly attributable
to the center-surround
organization or the receptive
fields or retinal ganglion
cells.
So what he proposed is that when
a retinal ganglion cell falls
in the center like this, there's
more inhibition in the surround
than when it falls along
not the intersections,
but along the straight lines.
And because of that, there's
more inhibition here than here,
and that's why we
see the smudges.
Now, that was a very
attractive theory.
And in fact, it has appeared and
still exists in many textbooks
that you read about illusions
and about vision in general.
Now, OK, so here is
the exact description
that I just made
to tell you this.
And of course, you would expect
that if this is the case,
you should also get the smudges
if you'd reverse the contrast.
And in fact, that is true.
So here, once again, you see
the smudges, maybe not quite
as sharp.
But in this case,
it's whiter smudges,
whereas in the previous
case, this one,
you have darker smudges.
So that kind of fits
with that basic idea.
But then, subsequently,
people began
to play around with various
conditions to see when you do
and when you don't
get the smudge effect
and to see whether that
would fit with this theory.
Now, that's the basic tenet
in just about everything
that psychologists
and neuroscientists
working in the visual system do.
They try to critically
examine various hypotheses.
And doesn't have to
be just illusions,
it can be a whole
bunch of other things.
And they do this then by
systematically manipulating
things in experiments that
can present these things just
under free viewing
conditions, as I'm doing it
in terms of these
handouts, or you
can do it under more
controlled conditions.
The subjects can look through
a tachistoscope or something
like that.
All right.
So anyway, let's now look
at this in a bit more detail
and see what's wrong
with this theory.
Well, first of all, if
you look at this figure,
what you can see here that
you can see the smudges
irrespective of the size
of the overall display.
Now, that's a problem
because, of course,
the size of the receptive
fields in the retina,
in their center-surround
arrangement, is constant.
So if it were the
sharp arrangement
that we described about the
way the center and the surround
are activated by
the intersections
and the non-intersections in
the display, that should not
apply to different sizes.
It should only work then
for a particular size
where you approximate that.
Now, I will elaborate on that
in more detail in just a minute.
Now, another bug
that arose here is
that if you now turn this
display just 45 degrees,
all right, so that it's a
diamond rather than a square,
the illusory effect has
declined considerably.
And then to make this
even more problematic,
and this appears in your
handout on that backside
of the first page,
what you can see here
is that when you make
the lines arranged
in such a fashion at slight
angles to each other, then
you don't see the
illusory effect at all.
Whereas here, we also see it
a little bit less but still
slightly visible.
But here it's not
visible at all.
And you can compare that even
better on the handout there.
So the question is,
why would that be?
Well, we give you
another example here.
If you make serrated
edges-- I don't
know if the people in the
back can see the serrations.
Those of you in front
can see the serrations.
And when you do that,
also you fail to see it.
And the problem
here, of course, is
that if you make these
slight changes in the angles
of the intersecting lines
or you make them serrated,
the center-surround
antagonism should be the same.
And yet such a small change
causes the illusory effect
to disappear.
So that then, in itself,
questions the Baumgartner
theory.
Now, there are several other
factors that enter into this.
This is a very subtle one.
If you look at this side,
OK, we have different shades
for the lines.
OK?
On this side, we have the
darkened lines, OK, in front.
And in this case, they
have them in the back.
And here you see the illusory
effect, and here you don't.
And once again, how can that
be if the illusory effect is
due to the center-surround
antagonism?
Even more dramatic is when
you do this with colors.
Here you have, again, the
colored lines in front,
and here you have
them in the back.
And here you can see
homonymous shades, all right?
This is darker yellow and so on.
But it's the same color
but a little bit darker
at the intersections.
So here you get a pretty
good illusory effect.
But once those white
lines are in front,
we get very little
effect at all.
So that then denotes a number
of problems with the theory.
And then one more fact is that
when you present the stimuli
at isoluminance, you don't
get an effect at all.
So that then raised
some serious questions
about the illusory effect.
And then a
quantitative study was
undertaken to see just what
is the layout of the receptive
fields in this display.
And so here what we
have is a display.
This square here is exactly five
degrees from your fixation, OK,
and you can calculate the number
of midget and parasol cells
that are activated
by that square area.
And you can see in total there
are more than 360 cells that
are being activated
in that little region.
And here is a display, in this
case, of only the ON cells,
and you can double
that by having the OFF
cells in the same location.
Saying that there's just
no good correspondence
whatsoever in the
number of ganglion cells
that are being activated and
how the center-surround is truly
laid out at a point where
you get a very good smudge
effect with this illusion.
So this then,
taken all together,
raises the issue then if indeed
there's a retina phenomenon,
why is there no fit here?
And so it does look
like that it's unlikely
that this illusion
can be explained
by the center-surround
antagonism theory.
So then another
theory was advanced
claiming that this doesn't
take place in the retina,
but instead that it takes
place in the cortex.
And so another theory
that was advanced
is saying that this happens
in the cortex due to the fact
that you have these
simple cells-- we talked
about those before-- that had
these elongated inhibitory,
supposedly
inhibitory, surrounds.
And if one calculates this,
that can explain the illusion
a little bit better,
especially since these cells,
even at any given point
in the visual cortex,
come in several different sizes.
So that's an alternate theory.
But still, further
research needs
to be done to be able to verify
whether this theory is more
valid than the center-surround
theory in the retina, which
certainly is totally wrong.
So I think maybe in
another 100 years,
they're going to drop the
Baumgartner theory out
from textbooks and general
reviews of illusions
and vision.
OK.
So now I want to show you one
more illusory effect, which
is a variant of the illusion
that I have just shown you.
And this one is something that
can drive you nuts, I suppose.
And that appears on the second
front page, the second sheet,
I should say, of the handout.
You can look at it there,
or you can look at it here.
And you can see this
scintillating effect,
and therefore it has been
called the scintillating grid
illusion.
It was invented by
fellow called Lingelbach.
All right?
That's a very strong illusory
effect, very dramatic.
And whether this
can be explained
by any particular theory
about the visual cortex
still remains to be settled.
Right now I don't think
there's a specific theory that
can explain this.
Now, I will now move
on and talk about yet
another illusory effect,
or actually a set of them,
that has a much
better explanation.
This one we don't
have a handout for.
If you look at
this display here,
you'll agree that the left and
right bars here are identical,
right, going in shade
from light to dark.
All right?
So now what I'm going to
do here-- what I want to do
is to present these
two images here.
I want you to fixate
in the fixation spot,
and we'll count to about,
I don't know, 20, say.
Keep fixating.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 20.
And then I'm going
to go back here,
and you can see that this side
is much darker than that one.
Everybody got that effect?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I'll do it once more.
Pretty dramatic, huh?
OK.
Now I'll tell you
what I'm going to do.
What I want you to do is to
look at this with one eye.
OK?
Don't look at it yet.
Wait a while.
Just let your eye get settled.
You're going to look
at it with one eye.
And then when I switch over,
I want you to switch eyes.
OK?
All right, ready?
Go ahead now and fixate,
and we'll count to 20 again.
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 20.
Switch.
And if you do that, you
don't have an effect.
OK?
So what does that prove?
Well, that obviously
proves-- that's why
it's nice to do these little,
itty-bitty experiments one can
do in minutes-- it proves
that this is a retinal effect.
And the effect is
actually due to adaptation
that we have talked about, when
was it, a couple of times ago.
Now, I want to show
you yet another effect
that has a similar arrangement.
What I'm going to do here is I'm
going to put this display on.
And what I'm going
to do here is I'm
going to turn these
off successively
as we go around the clock.
OK?
And what I want
you to do, again,
is to fixate here
on the cross, OK,
and then I'm going
to start running it.
And what are you going to see?
A pretty amazing thing
you're going to see.
What do you see?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
You see a green
spot going around?
Everybody see that?
OK.
So now the big question
comes up, why on earth
do we see this green spot?
What is the explanation?
Well, this again is
a retinal effect.
And to test this
in more detail, we
have to go back to what I
told you about color vision.
And when I told you
about color vision--
if you remember we did that
experiment with Gaussians--
that if you look at the color
circle, all right, and then
you adapt to a stimulus here,
which is pretty similar to what
was on the screen,
then the afterimage
is on the opposite side cutting
across the color circle.
So the afterimages that
you see that are in color
can be perfectly explained
by the color circle.
If you adapt to this,
this is the afterimage.
You adapt to this,
It's always straight across
the center line, center point,
I should say, where you have the
white center, which perfectly
explains your afterimage.
So what I'll do again, I'll
show this to you just once more.
OK, here we go, ready?
You can experience it again
just to sort of get a sense.
It's amazing how
the green circle
becomes more and more
and more and more vivid.
Now, one more thing
I'm going to tell
you is when I turn this
off-- keep fixating--
and then you're going to see
a green afterimage, right?
So it proves that, indeed,
it's the afterimage that
appears over a period of time
with that rotating circle,
and it's fully explained
by the color circle.
All right.
So now we're going
to move on, and you
look at yet another
illusory effect.
If you look at this display,
what do you see here?
You see a light square
and a dark square, right?
Everybody see that?
Now, what if I told you
that what you're seeing
is a total misconception?
So I'll tell you
what I'm going to do.
I'm going to leave these two
squares exactly as they are,
but I'm going to
change the background.
Ready?
What's the difference here?
The difference is that now the
background is uniform, right?
And you can see these
two squares are indeed
identical in contrast, right?
But now if I go back
to the previous one,
if you look at it
more carefully you
can see this goes
from light to dark.
Of course, the projector
makes this look bluish.
It shouldn't be, but that's OK.
And it's a gradual shift
in the illumination level
that fools you to think that
one is light, the other is dark.
And that has to do
heavily with the fact
that the receptive fields
of cells in the retina
have center-surround
organization,
and they're sensitive to
local contrast differences.
That's their make-up.
And so until I
point it out to you,
can't even tell that
this is a gradual shift.
And if it did not
change in color,
it would be harder to tell.
And it has to do with
the fact that you're
making local comparisons.
And because of that, to
make a distant comparison
you are inaccurate about it.
So this illusory effect,
again, can be readily explained
on the basis of what we know
about the center-surround
organization of receptive
fields in the retina.
OK.
Now, if you look at the
same thing in color, which
doesn't come up too well here
because of the projector,
but still you can tell that
these are not the same color,
OK, again because of
the gradual shift,
color shift, in the background.
But exactly identical they
are, as they had been before.
So this works not
only for contrast,
but it also works for color.
Now, some illusory effects don't
work for color and some do.
All right.
So now yet another
related effect
that I'm sure some
of you have seen
before is if you
look at this circle,
we agree that it's
uniform in color.
Now, if I cover half of it with
dark and the other with light,
it still looks pretty the same.
Maybe it's a little
darker here than here.
But then if I put a partition
here, as you can see here,
then this side definitely
looks darker than that side.
OK?
So this, again, looks
at contrast effects,
and we'll talk about these
contrasts in just a bit
with more detail.
Next, let me turn to
another illusory effect
that you can see in many,
many textbooks, which
is called the
wallpaper illusion.
If you look at this--
I'll come to it
in a second in your display,
where it will appear
on the back of the second
page-- what you see here,
it looks like that these
are not parallel lines here.
I shouldn't say
lines, but parallel
black and white squares.
It looks like that they're going
like back and forth like that,
OK, and it's quite dramatic.
And so now we can ask the
question, how can we see this?
What is this due to?
It could be due to the
way they're aligned.
It could be due to
the fact that there
is space between
them, that gray space.
And so one can do
experiments like the one
you have on your
next page there.
Let me first-- I will
prove that, indeed, we
have parallel lines here.
These are fully parallel lines,
and they go back and forth.
To convince you, you can see
that the lines are identical,
and yet they do
not look parallel
at all because of
this illusory effect.
OK.
So now what we can do is we can
fiddle around with this a bit.
Now, that's the kind of
thing you guys would probably
enjoy doing yourselves--
look at various illusions
and start playing
around with them.
This is an example.
This is a basic
wallpaper illusion.
And now you turn this into
an equal checkerboard, OK?
And if you keep the
lines in between,
and you get no
effect whatsoever.
And then here we
eliminate those gray bars,
and the illusory effect
is greatly reduced.
So consequently,
the illusory effect
has to do with both
the fact that you
have space between the
alternating black and white
bars, meaning these
gray lines here,
and that you have them offset.
So when it's not offset,
you don't get it.
And when you don't have
the bars, you don't get it.
So these two factors
play an important role
in giving rise to
the illusory effect.
Now, what we also can examine
is what happens at isoluminance.
And in this case, once
again, what happens
is that the illusory
effect is still there,
but it is reduced under
isoluminant conditions.
And this is not the
isoluminant actually
because of the projector.
But when it's
perfectly isoluminant,
then the illusory
effect is largely lost.
All right.
So now we have a variant of this
illusion which is fascinating.
And this one I will show
you on the next page, OK?
And if you look at
just this display,
and you are convinced that we
have lines that are alternating
that are filtered
back and forth, right?
Well, is that really true?
Well, it turns out if you
take a bunch of red lines here
that are perfectly
parallel, OK, and then you
superimpose those
on the display,
you can see that actually
the display is parallel.
OK?
The reason it
doesn't look parallel
is due to the way these
individual little pieces
that you're not even
conscious of are arranged.
So let's look at
that in more detail.
Let me add here one more thing.
At isoluminance, you get
practically no effect.
So these illusions, this
one and the previous one,
heavily depend on
contrast differences.
OK.
So here we go.
Here's the basic
illusory effect.
And the way this was constructed
is shown enlarged on top.
Alternate lines have
1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 2, 1.
OK?
What you have in the top line,
and the third, and so on,
you have it in this orientation.
Here you have them reversed.
And that vague cue
is what somehow
provides the illusory
effect for you.
Now, if you make all
the lines similar,
OK, in other words don't
reverse the alternate lines,
then what you see
here is actually
the bars are all
tilted slightly upward.
OK?
And because of that,
the illusory effect
is not as dramatic as this
one, but you still have it.
All right?
So what then you
can do with this
is to enlarge on this
effect as shown here.
It looks like that you have
somehow a very unequal set
of lines, as a result
of which you do not
have a bunch of
clear-cut squares.
And if you, again, superimpose
true parallel lines through it,
you see that they are
actually parallel.
All right.
So that then explains
that illusory effect
in terms of how we somehow
integrate information of shape
that we are not even
aware of to have
a perception of a whole thing.
Now, that's not much
of an explanation.
It doesn't tell you what
neurons are involved
or anything like that.
But it gives you
a general concept
of how that illusory
effect is created.
Now we come to yet another
fascinating illusory effect,
and that one is in the next
few pages in the handout.
So if you take the
backside of page 3,
you will see this
illusory effect here.
Does everybody see that?
Now, this illusory effect is
one which gives you a sense
that you have a whole
bunch of swirls.
All right?
Does everybody see those swirls?
Instead of seeing 1, 2, 3, 4
circles, you see some swirls.
And you say what on earth
is giving us that sensation?
So what you want to do then
is to look at it analytically.
And what you see
here is you have
alternating black and white
squares, first of all.
And you say, well,
is alternating
black and white squares
the central point?
But then if you look
at it more closely,
you can see this is-- I
don't know how they came up
with this one-- what you see
here, if you look at each
of these, that there's a
gradual shift as you go
around the circle in the
orientation of the square.
So this square
becomes progressively,
very slowly, more rotated.
OK?
And that goes around
the clock, and that's
true for every one
of those circles.
And you can say, well, is it due
to the black and white squares?
Is it due to the change in
the orientation of the squares
that you're not even aware of?
Or what?
So what kind of
experiment do you
do to check this out, to come
up with some understanding?
What kind of game can you play?
Well, the first
game you can play,
so you can say,
well, let's eliminate
these slight changes
in orientation.
OK?
And so what you can do instead,
as shown on the next page,
is that you have a
bunch of circles,
black and white circles,
which are all the same.
And as you can see
here, there's no swirls.
You have four
circles, very clear.
So therefore,
obviously, the squares,
changing their orientation in
a subtle fashion going around
in the clock, is very
important in introducing
this illusory effect.
Well, then you can say,
OK, but is that all of it?
And so what we can do here,
as shown on the next page,
is we can maintain
the orientation shift,
but we can make them all the
same contrast, as we have here.
And when you do that, you have
have a rather weak illusory
effect.
There's still a little bit left
maybe, but it's kind of weak.
And then if you instead
make it isoluminant,
you get some in-between effect.
So on the basis of
that, we can conclude
that very important
in this display
is that you have a gradual
shift in the orientations
of these squares.
And that, in turn, suggests that
somehow the way these squares
activate orientation
selective cells in V1
plays an important
role in giving rise
to this strange illusory effect.
OK.
So now what we
are going to do is
to look at yet another
illusory effect, which
has a different
source, and that one
is the famous
Muller-Lyer illusion.
The fact is that
these two bars here
are identical in size-- do I
have the picture-- like that.
OK?
But when you put these inducing
elements, as we will call them,
OK, on there, you'll swear
that this one is longer
than this one is.
OK?
So now we can ask the question,
what kind of manipulations
can we undertake to see
what that is all about?
And let me come back
to that in a minute.
So what you can
do here is to make
the inducing elements and
the bars different in color
or in contrast, and you still
get a strong illusory effect.
OK?
So making them
isoluminant or making them
opposite in contrast does
not eliminate this illusion.
So the theory that
somebody has come up with
is shown here, which
I'm not sure I buy,
but that's
nevertheless a theory,
it claims that the
brain interprets
these two displays as
differences in depth,
as if here we had a protruding
edge in a building inside
or a receding edge
as shown here.
And that difference that
we almost unconsciously,
if you will, interpret as
being in different depths
is what gives rise
to the illusion
according to this theory.
Of course, there's a
simpler theory simply saying
that we just integrate these
two bits of information.
All right.
So now we can ask the question,
if you have illusory effects
of this sort, is this something
that really takes place higher
up in the brain, or does it take
place in the retina where we
cannot separate these
inducing and testing elements?
Well, the way you
can do this-- I'm
going to show you
another illusion which
is similar to this.
Here we have the so-called
Ebbinghaus illusion.
This is a very similar
kind of illusion.
This is a test element
and an inducing element.
The test element here
are these two circles,
and you swear that
this one is a smaller
circle than that one is, right?
And we have a bunch
of small circles,
and here we have bunch
of large circles.
So now we can ask,
well, is this something
that takes place in
the retina or what?
So what kind of
experiment can you do?
Well, the experiment
that you can do
is to present these
displays interocularly.
What does that mean?
What that means is
that you present this
to the left eye and
this to the right eye.
And you present
this device that's
used by psychologists
for this kind of thing.
It's called a tachistoscope.
You look through it.
It can present things
separately through the two eyes,
and you can flash
them on briefly
so you don't get any
binocular rivalry.
And when you do that, then
you can systematically
vary the size of
these to make sure
that you can get a
quantitative measure of it.
And when you do that, you
find that the illusory effect
is just as good under
interocular conditions
as it is under binocular
viewing conditions.
Because of this
then-- this has been
done with many
kinds of illusions
including the Muller-Lyer one.
And when you do that,
you show, in essence,
that this is an effect
that takes place
most likely in the
cortex, certainly
not in the retina or the
lateral geniculate nucleus.
It takes place someplace
where the images
from the left and
two eyes converge.
All right.
So now yet another
set of illusions
that I want to show you.
I think that these
illusory effects are done.
You can take this home and enjoy
it or show it to your friends.
Now I'm going to show
you a set of just two
kinds of motion illusions.
OK, here's the first one.
I want you to look
at the screen,
and I'm going to flash
something on briefly,
and I'm going to
do it repeatedly.
Ready?
What do you see?
Do you see something moving?
A very brief sense of
motion that you see.
This twirls a little bit.
And this is called
the snake illusion,
which is really curious.
This has, again, appeared in
quite a number of textbooks,
and we do not have a really
good explanation for it.
But we have another one,
which I think is related.
OK.
So what I'm going
to do here, this
is called the
waterfall illusion.
So what we are
going to do here is
I'm going to set this in motion.
In this case, I don't
want you to fixate.
What I want you
to do is just keep
looking at it in various places.
You can look here, here,
here, and here, and so on.
OK?
And I'm going to let
it run for a while,
and then I'm going to stop it.
OK?
And I want you to tell me
what is your aftereffect.
Ready?
OK.
I'm about to stop it.
Are you ready?
Pay close attention
to what you're
going to perceive once it stops.
Anybody see what happened?
What did you see?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You see the water
running up here, right?
OK.
I'll do it once more so
you can appreciate it.
Pretty nice, huh?
OK.
So this illusory effect is one
that also occurs interocularly.
And it has been shown that
when you record from area MT,
we talked about the fact that
area MT is a region where cells
respond selectively to
direction of motion.
Well, people have
shown that if you,
for an extended period of time,
a minute maybe or whatever,
you stimulate a cell in MT
with this kind of a display,
then after you stop it, OK, the
cells with the opposite sense
of motion will
discharge some, which
then is attributable to the
upward sensation that you have.
So it's clear enough
that this is something
that does take place
predominantly by virtue
of direction-selective
cells and, probably,
by direction-selective
cells in area MT.
All right.
So then what we are
going to do here
is we're going to look
at some other limitations
and ambiguities in perception.
And in particular,
we're going to examine
some figure/ground
relationships.
The first one I'm going
to show you is this one.
If you look at these two
diagonals, OK, a and b,
they certainly look very,
very different, don't they?
OK?
One looks shorter and
a different angle.
But now if I eliminate the
trapezoid in the surround,
you can see that they're
actually identical.
OK?
I'll show it to you again.
Pretty dramatic.
So that's an interesting
illusory effect.
And it's clear enough
that this is something
that takes place in
higher cortical areas.
Yet another one here that
I'm going to show you also
has something to do with
figure/ground relationships,
which has been
extensively studied,
especially by Gestalt
psychologists.
And I spoke about this a
little bit the last time.
What you see here is a bunch
of vases, so to speak, right?
That's good enough.
So what I'm going
to do now, I'm going
to show you another
set of vases.
Are you ready?
There is another set of vases.
Everybody see the vases?
Now, what if I tell
you that there's
much more to this
than just vases?
So if you look really
closely, you're
going to see
something else there.
What else do you see there?
AUDIENCE: Faces.
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK, two faces,
two guys facing each other.
Now, if I change the relative
number of elements in here,
which changes the
figure/ground relationships,
you get a different effect.
Here you have--
predominantly you
see the faces rather
than the vases.
OK?
And that's a cute
way of putting it.
I see the faces, not the vases.
And then you switch
it, and you say,
I see the vases, not the faces.
All right?
So that then is a way you
can play around, again,
with various illusory
effects by fiddling around
on your computer and
creating things like that.
OK.
Now, yet another
strange effect is
where you can have
difficulty telling what's
what is this kind of a display.
You say, well, what's
happening here?
Are arrows pointing
to the right,
or are they pointing
to the left?
And that reminds one of a
fellow called Yogi Berra.
How many of you have
ever heard of Yogi Berra?
Oh, my goodness, very good.
OK.
So he was a famous catcher for
the New York Yankees, right?
Well, he was a very
interesting guy,
had all kinds of
interesting statements.
And one of those many curious
statements, one of them
is-- it doesn't relate to this.
It just comes into my head.
"It isn't over until it's over."
That's one of his, OK?
This one here
that's relevant is,
"When you get to a fork
in the road, take it."
Yeah?
And that's a Yogi Berra quote.
And so what we have
here is a sign that you
come to a fork in the road, and
you have to decide to take it.
What are you going to do?
Are you going to go this way,
or are you going to go that way?
So that's a kind of
game you can play
with this kind of strange
effect that you can create
that is confusing your
ability to organize
your visual percepts.
Another famous one, maybe
not that famous, actually.
Maybe some of you
have seen this.
This, again, has appeared many,
many years ago in The New.
Yorker.
It says, "I'm turning
into my mother."
Now, keep looking
at it and tell me,
why do you think that that
comment is being made?
What we have here, a young woman
looking at another young woman,
right?
But now if you keep looking
at this display, look.
This is a nose here,
and this is a mouth.
You see an old lady now?
OK.
You played around with this, it
gives you a confusing percept.
And ultimately, you can
see the young person
looking that way or an old
lady looking the other way.
I mean looking not
backwards but across.
And that's why this
statement says,
"I'm turning into my mother."
So the essence here
is that playing around
with these kinds of illusory
effect is a lot of fun,
and we all very much enjoy
looking at illusions.
And some of us like to
play around with them
to try to figure out what their
existence is for the reasons.
Now, I want to
show you one more,
which I think is very
appropriate at this time.
This is the famous
Greek key motif.
Everybody's seen
this, I presume.
Does everybody know where
this is displayed, actually,
at several places?
In the Senate.
OK?
Whenever you have a picture
of the Senate Building,
you will see this.
All right?
Now, that's a little
bit amusing, actually,
if you think about it.
So this has become
symbolic of democracy.
And considering just what
happened most recently,
you could almost
say that, perhaps,
what's happening here is that
you cannot tell whether we see
this guy or this guy
here going around.
OK?
And one of them you could say,
oh, these are the Democrats.
These are the Republicans.
And you have sort of a conflict
as to which ones you see.
All right?
And that is, in a way, symbolic
of what's going on today.
But to educate you
a little bit, which
I suspect probably most of
you know already anyway,
this Greek key motif
actually has its source
in the so-called
myth of the Labyrinth
that had imprisoned
the Minotaur.
Who knows who the Minotaur is?
Oh, very good.
Many of you do.
All right.
So the Minotaur
was a creature that
was half bull and half human.
All right?
And what happened, according to
this myth-- and let me tell you
it's a myth, and it's
a bit of risque thing.
There was a king
called King Minos
whose wife Pasiphae--
Pasiphae, I'm not sure
how you pronounce it properly--
is the one who had intercourse
with a bull and
gave birth-- sorry,
had intercourse with a bull.
And as a result of
that, gave birth
to the Minotaur, which was a
half-bull, half-human monster,
if you will.
All right?
And that became so
threatening and so irritating,
I guess, to King
Minos that he asked
one of his subjugates, Daedalus,
to create a maze, a huge maze,
and he put the Minotaur in it.
So it was such a maze
that the Minotaur just
couldn't get out of it.
All right?
But then things got
progressively worse,
and King Minos decided
that he had better
get this Minotaur killed.
And so he asked a person
whose name is Theseus, OK,
to go into the maze
and kill the Minotaur.
Now, the king also
had another offspring
whose name is Ariadne--
nice name, Ariadne.
And she said to Theseus that
if you take a ball of thread
and you walk through
the maze, once you
do what you have to do, you
can follow the thread back,
and that way you can
get out of the maze.
So that's what Theseus
did, and then he
went on and killed the Minotaur.
Now, the story didn't end
there because somehow,
for reasons I'm not sure I
know the details anymore,
King Minos had a fall
out with Daedalus,
and he jailed Daedalus
and his son Icarus.
And while they
were in jail, they
tried to figure out
how they could escape.
And so Daedalus
fashioned a pair of wings
made out of bird's feathers and
wax, and then put it on Icarus.
And then Icarus, by
doing this, he could fly.
OK?
And then he flew and
escaped from the prison.
But unfortunately, he
flew fairly high up
where the sun was very hot.
That melted the wax, and
Icarus, sadly, fell to his death
as a result.
So that's quite the story.
And that's something that
obviously some of you
already know.
And those of you who
don't, you will probably
remember, as so many Greek
myths are just fascinating,
ancient, old stories.
All right.
So then here is actually
a reconstruction
of the kill of the
Minotaur by Theseus.
And this is actually a
sculpture that exists in Greece.
Pretty nice, huh?
OK.
Now, the last confusing image
that I wanted to show you
is this one that had appeared--
I think this appeared also
in The New Yorker,
but I'm not 100% sure.
What you have here
is a confusion--
do we have three
or two prongs here?
And the reason I show
this sometimes in class
is because in our department
when it was originally
formed by Hans-Lukas
Teuber, he created
what is called three prongs.
OK?
And then it became sort
of an issue as to, well,
what are the three prongs?
Are there two prongs?
Are there three prongs?
Who belongs into which prong?
And so somebody came
up with this picture
that was put up as a joke
in the department when
the department was still in
one of the old buildings that
doesn't even exist anymore.
All right.
So that then brings me to the
end of the illusory effects
that I thought we'd
talk about briefly.
And I will now move on and
talk about visual prosthesis.
All right.
Now, as far as
prosthetics are concerned,
you're going to hear quite a
bit about that from Chris Brown
because in audition, an auditory
prosthetic device, the cochlear
implant, has become
an incredible success.
There are well over 50,000
people in the country now
who have a prosthetic
device like that
that enables them to
hear, to converse.
It's really incredible.
Unfortunately, when it
comes to visual prostheses,
we have nothing
comparable at this stage.
It's a much needed device that
will take many, many, many more
years to create.
But I thought I'd give you
sort of a crude sense of how
that kind of work
progresses because there are
many laboratories that
are trying to come up
with something that will provide
an ability for people to see.
Now, I can tell you
that in the world
there are more than 40
million people who are blind.
In the United States, there are
more than a million individuals
who are blind.
So because of that--
that's a huge number--
it, of course, is extremely
desirable to come up
with some device
to do this for you.
Now, this is a very,
very long history,
and people have tried
all sorts of things.
One of those is to try to induce
the ability to see something
in the world that you
normally see with your eye
by putting it through
some other sense.
Now, a simple example
of that is Braille.
All right?
Everybody knows what
Braille is, right?
That's you can use your
hand to feel something that
has protruding
elements in it that
can be shown in
terms of letters.
And so as you get into an
elevator and you can't see,
you can feel it, and then
you can push the right button
to get to the right floor.
OK?
Now, that's one way
it has been done.
Another approach had been
to present stimulation
to your somatosensory system,
either by putting something
on your back or putting
something on your fingertip,
that an image would be converted
into actually activating
your somatosensory
system that would
be equivalent to something that
you would perceive if you could
see.
So that's the basic thing.
And a tremendous
amount of effort
has been going on to try to
come up with something to create
a workable prosthetic
device for the blind.
Now, there's a lot
of disagreement
as to where such a device
should be placed in the body
and also a lot of debate
of what kind of procedures
should be used.
Now, some people
advocate that it
should be done on the retina.
Some people advocate
it should be
done in the lateral
geniculate nucleus.
Actually, some
work is being done
at Harvard trying to
come up with something
for the lateral
geniculate nucleus.
And there's some
people who think
it would be best to do
it in the visual cortex.
So let me sort of go into
this in a bit more detail.
And let me, first of all,
raise the question of,
what kinds of devices, and
what kinds of necessities
do we have for converting
vision into something
that enables blind
people to see?
Well, first of all,
it's very important
to be able to see some basic
patterns, very important to see
motion, and very
important, often ignored,
is that you got to be
able to see something
in the third dimension,
because a person who is blind,
he should be able to
walk in the world.
And if you're going
to walk around,
you should be able to see
where things are in depth.
So those are the
basic requirements.
You're certainly not required
to process color information.
So that's not important.
And there are several other
things that are not important.
But these are the three
most important ones
that you would like to
have if you are going
to create a prosthetics
device for the blind.
Now, then the next
question is, how are we
going to deal with
this, and what kinds
of issues and problems
are we going to deal with?
First of all, the big issue is
what kind of prosthetic device
should we use.
One of those that
I've already mentioned
is to try to convert
visual impressions
into other modalities such
as your somatosensory system.
All right?
The other is to create some
sort of stimulating device,
which there are various kinds.
But one of those
would be, for example,
to put a bunch of
electrodes into the brain,
or into the retina, or whatever,
and then selectively stimulate
through this series
of electrodes
to mimic the visual field.
Now, the other one,
and it is a big issue,
what brain areas
should be considered?
And because we're at
an early stage in this,
I think it is
desirable for people
to pursue just about any
area they think might work.
Now, the problem with
a retinal implant--
there are two problems with it.
One is the retina is extremely
small, and very confined,
and has these millions of
receptors and ganglion cells,
and how can you
selectively activate them?
Now, the biggest
problem, though,
is that in most blind
people, the retina
becomes non-functional.
And even worse, it degenerates
in a relatively short time
so that it no longer is useful
for electrical stimulation
or for whatever
kind of stimulation
you wish to engage in.
So because of that,
some people have
moved on to the lateral
geniculate nucleus.
That area has some problems
because it's deep in the brain,
and it's quite small.
OK?
And also, it tends to
degenerate over time,
although it takes it a lot
longer than the degeneration
of the retina.
Thirdly, people have considered
stimulating the visual cortex,
and that's what
I'm going to talk
about in a bit more
detail just now.
But the last thing that's very
important here-- I think it's
the last thing.
Yeah, just let me go back.
Ah, sorry.
The third big issue
is, can you create
a device that has longevity?
As soon as you put
something into the brain
and into the eye,
there's going to be
some sort of adverse
reaction that
may kill the cells at
the tip of the electrodes
or something like that.
So all kinds of
approaches have been
created to try to increase
the longevity of the device.
Now, I'm going to
next look at what
happens in the
visual cortex, which
is a promising, at least I
think it is, a promising site
where you could electrically
stimulate and use
that to create a
visual impression.
All right.
If you do that-- here
is a monkey brain.
The monkey is very
well suited for this
because, as I have mentioned
before, the posterior
part of the cortex-- see, this
is area V1-- is lissencephalic.
And so it's relatively easy
to place accurately electrodes
into it.
OK?
So then if what you do
here-- here, just a reminder,
is the central sulcus.
Here's the lunate sulcus.
And here, of course, is area V1.
If you now take the
contralateral hemifield,
that projects into this region.
OK?
This is shown out to
about five degrees.
That will go to
around here like that.
OK?
So now the next big
question that, initially,
had been done
actually in humans,
what do you see when you
insert a microelectrode
into the brain-- as I say, this
was done on humans initially--
and you electrically stimulate?
What do you see?
And this work was done by
Brindley many years ago.
And he discovered that
when you electrically
stimulate in the human primary
visual cortex, what you get
is a small, star-like image.
All right?
So that's what he found.
And so that then triggered
a great deal of research,
including work in
monkeys, to determine
what could be done to create
a prosthetic device that
might just work.
So the first step
then was to try
to determine what
happens when you
put a microelectrode in here.
This is, by the way, the
layout of the visual field
in the posterior cortex
with much more area devoted
to the fovea than into the
periphery because, of course,
there's a much higher packing
density of receptor cells
as well as retinal
ganglion cells in the fovea
representation than further out.
In the cortex, the thickness
of the gray matter is constant.
It's about roughly
2 millimeters thick.
And the frequency, spatial
frequency of the cells,
is pretty constant as well.
So therefore, you need
to allocate more space
to the incoming huge
number of retinal ganglion
cells projected
to the geniculate
and then to the cortex
than for the periphery.
And that's why
you have this kind
of a layout of much
more space allocated
to the central than
to peripheral vision.
So that's a very
important factor
in considering how to
create a prosthetic device.
So now the first step in
doing this kind of stuff,
if you're going to do serious
experiments on monkeys,
is to determine,
what does the monkey
see when you electrically
stimulate the visual cortex?
And so the experiment
that's been done here
is one in which a
monkey has been trained
to make an eye movement to the
bigger of two visual stimuli
or the brighter of two stimuli.
In this case, we have
two visual targets.
By the way, one
of these is going
to appear where the receptive
field is of the cells
that you're going to stimulate
in the visual cortex.
So then you may sometimes make
this one brighter, this one
brighter.
And the monkey makes
a saccade to it,
and he gets a drop of
apple juice for reward.
And then you can systematically
vary the relative size
of the two stimuli to see what
kind of a function you get.
And the same thing you can do
for the relative brightness
of it.
And then on some trials
interspersed with those trials,
you present
[INAUDIBLE] stimulation
with the visual
target and see which
one does the monkey go to.
And then you
systematically vary,
as I said, the brightness or
the size of those stimuli.
OK?
We vary the contrast in
this case, and in this case,
we vary the size.
OK?
So that's the basic experiment.
And if you do that
systematically,
you can tell exactly what
the size and the contrast
is of the visual
stimulus created
by electrical stimulation.
If you do that--
here's an example.
When you present
two visual stimuli
and you vary the percent
contrast difference, all right,
of the two stimuli, you can see
that it crosses over, indeed,
when they're identical.
So that tells you that
this system works.
It says these are identical.
And the same thing is
true for the size series.
So this way then, if you
do the same experiment
with electrical stimulation,
you can find out
where this 50%
crossover point is.
This is for contrast,
and this is for size.
So then you can establish
this with slightly different
locations in the visual field.
And if you do that
overall, you come up
with a summary
statement, which says
that when you use currents
between 20 and 120 microamps,
OK, at eccentricities between 2
and 1/2 and 3 and 1/2 degrees,
the contrast of the visual
percept created in monkeys
is 6% to 12%, and the size
is between 15 and 20 minutes
of visual angle.
Now, that's quite
small fortunately.
So it's a local, little
spot, like a star-like image.
Now, what do we mean
by 6% to 12% contrast?
So let me tell you
this, that that's
a useful thing for
you to memorize.
We talk about percent contrast.
What you do is you
measure, for example,
in candelas per square
meter, what the contrast is
of this and what is the
contest of the background.
Then you subtract one
from the other, divide it
by the sum of the two,
and you multiply by 100.
So when you do that, this
is roughly 8% contrast.
This is roughly 75% contrast.
So it gives you a sense
of what contrast means.
All right?
So what that means, in essence,
that the visual stimulus
created by the
electrical stimulation
is fairly low contrast.
All right.
So now the next
important factor,
once one knows what
the visual percept is
that is created by electrical
stimulation in the monkey,
the next thing is to
ask the question, well,
what kind of electrode array
should one put together?
All right.
Well, the big issue
here has to do
with the so-called
magnification factor
that I just talked about.
So let's look at
this analytically.
First of all, I
already mentioned this.
We have a very high packing
density of photoreceptors
in the fovea and much
lower density further out.
And so what you have
is that this plate
goes through the optic nerve
up to the visual cortex
to the lateral
geniculate nucleus.
So that's the basic
arrangement, meaning
that there are many, many
more retinal ganglion
cells per unit area that
impinge on the visual cortex
near the fovea than
in the periphery.
So then to examine this, here
we have, again, another picture.
It's the geniculate again.
Here's the fact that the cortex
is constant in thickness.
And here's the layout of the
visual field on the posterior
cortex with more area
allocated to the fovea
than to-- excuse me,
than to periphery.
All right.
So now I've shown you a
variant of this before.
If you present an arrow
across the visual field here,
this is the impression made
with much more activation
in central vision than
in peripheral vision.
I mean, you don't have
to worry about that.
That simply tells you, as
we had discussed before,
that the images
created depend heavily
on where you stimulate
in the visual field.
OK.
So now to look at
this quantitatively,
so we put a bunch of dots
up in the visual field.
This is in the
central four degrees,
and this is the
actual activation
in the visual cortex.
OK?
Meaning that in the fovea,
we have two elements here,
this one and this one, here
and here, that they take up
a lot of space, whereas
in the periphery,
OK, they're very
close to each other.
That's due to the so-called
magnification factor.
And so one of the basic
rules is that we've
got to be able to stimulate
the visual cortex taking
into account the
magnification factor.
So if you have this kind
of spatial arrangement,
if we then were to put
a bunch of electrodes
in like this, which we will
call proportional electrodes,
then if you
stimulated all those,
you would get a similar
square with one proviso,
namely that the little dots
would be smaller in the fovea,
obviously, than
in the periphery.
So then if you have this kind
of arrangement, what you can do
is you can take a camera that
has a fixed number of elements,
and each of those
elements you hook up
to one of the electrodes.
If you put the word
"fiat lux" there,
this is what you hypothetically
would create, like that.
OK?
That's what it would look like.
So in contrast with
this arrangement,
if we were to use
an electrode array,
which you can readily buy-- you
cannot buy proportional arrays.
You have to somehow
create them yourself.
But if you buy a fixed
array, which the elements are
equidistant, then if
you stimulated all those
you would get a butterfly
image, butterfly image.
I will show a movie
of that as well.
And that means that if you do
that same conversion as before,
this is what you would
see in contrast to this.
So in other words, it's a
greatly distorted vision
because you didn't take into
account the magnification
factor.
All right.
So then what you can
do, actually, you
can also increase the number of
electrodes in the center here.
OK?
And that would
mean-- in this case
we have 428 elements-- that you
can recreate fiat lux pretty
well with this increased
number of elements,
where with the original set
you couldn't make anything out.
Now, the alternate
to this would be
that you could
take a whole bunch
of equally-spaced electrodes,
which you can commercially buy,
and put them in.
But then to get the same acuity,
you would need, in this case,
something like over
600 electrodes,
whereas in this case you
would only need about 420.
So because of that,
obviously we want
to minimize the number of
things you put into the brain,
it's desirable to use
a proportional device.
So that's the first big step.
Now, let's assume that you have
created a proportional device.
The next thing would be to
see, how do you stimulate these
through a camera?
So what you do then
is an experiment
in which you take
a human subject,
and you can put a
camera on a helmet,
and also, the person
looks at a monitor.
And otherwise, the
rest of the world
is excluded by having
this bezel here.
And then the camera
looks at something,
and then it can
display the image here.
Well, one thing it can do, it
can display the image as it is.
But the other thing that's
much more important,
it can display that image
as if electrical stimulation
had taken place.
Now, this becomes
complicated because you
have to do a lot of conversion
of the input from the camera
to the computer that's going
to then drive the electrodes.
Now, the first important
point, I mentioned this before,
is that if you present a small
spot-- this is actual real data
here-- you present a small spot
in the center of a small array
of cells in the visual cortex,
you get a vigorous response,
whether a light increment
or light decrement.
But if you use a larger
spot, you get no response,
meaning that the cortical cells
look at local differences.
That has a lot to do
with what we talked about
with the illusions.
And so what you
have to create is
an algorithm that mimics that.
And so the way
you do that is you
have these individual elements
for each of the electrodes.
And if that individual
element in the computer that
gets the input from the camera,
if the whole element gets
activated, there's no real
activation of the electrode.
But if an edge
appears like here,
here, or here, then the
electrode is activated.
OK?
So you create local differences
by this conversion system,
all right, by this
algorithm that then,
when the camera
looks at the world,
will respond whenever there's
an edge, an illumination
difference.
OK.
So now the way this
looks is like this.
Again, as I've told you,
whatever is in the fovea,
the dots are smaller and
further out, but that's OK.
So that's the basic
activation system.
And so now what we
are going to do,
having created
such an algorithm,
we're going to examine
what the person who
carries this camera on
his head can actually see.
Now, the way this can be done,
you can either physically
move the stimuli in the world,
or the person looks at it
and can slowly move
his head around.
OK?
So let's first
look at what would
happen if, instead of
a proportional display,
we used an equally-spaced
display like that butterfly
display.
OK?
So what I'm going to
show you here on the left
is what the camera is viewing.
And here I'm going to
show you what is actually
perceived by this algorithm, by
the person, where this image is
converted into what he's
looking at through that bezel.
OK, you ready?
I mean, you don't see
a square at all, right?
What you see is, because
you're not taking into account
the magnification factor,
you get a huge distortion.
So now let's go move on
and ask the question,
well, what happens when you are
using a proportional display?
All right?
And now we get a
rather nice story.
Again, the visual
display's on the left,
and the image created
is on the right.
Ready?
So the rule,
therefore, is that you
must use a proportional image,
proportional display, that
can be done either by having it
truly proportional as you put
it into the visual cortex or by
having an equally-spaced array,
and the computer computes
the proportional arrangement.
But the disadvantage
of the latter
is that you need many,
many more electrodes.
All right.
Now, what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to show you whether
you can read something
when you use a proportional
display like that.
And in this case, we're going
to have a bunch of big letters,
and either the letters
are going to move slowly
across the visual
field, or your head
is going to move slowly
with the camera like that
to view that display
that's up on the wall.
OK?
So if we do that--
are you ready?
See if you can read it.
OK.
Everybody able to read that one?
Who remembers what
"fiat lux" means?
I've only shown it about
four or five times.
Let there be light.
OK.
So now, just to be [INAUDIBLE]
attractive about it,
I'm going to show
you one more display.
And this one is
a display, again,
a series of letters
and words, is one
that John F. Kennedy has used in
a very, very famous statement,
which I think most
of you will remember.
And eventually, as you
see the whole thing,
you will be able
to put it together.
Are you ready?
OK.
Everybody's seen that, right?
People nowadays, because
of what's going on,
are less inclined
to take his advice.
All right.
So that is then
the essence of what
I was going to cover today.
And so let me now provide
you with a brief summary.
I will start with
the prosthetics then.
OK?
Research on visual
prosthetics is in its infancy,
as I've noted.
A great deal of
basic research is
needed before such a device
can become effective.
That's very unlike
what you're going
to hear about the
auditory system.
The brain area that holds
considerable promise
for the prosthetic device
based on electrical stimulation
is area V1.
Now, a prosthetic device for
electrical stimulation of V1
must take into account
the magnification factor.
That's absolutely
essential, and too many
people are ignoring it.
Now, in a different
color, we're going
to talk about the illusions.
There is no unitary
explanation for
the great many visual
illusions extant.
I pointed out to you
that different illusions
have different sources and
different explanations.
The most popular theory
explaining the Hermann grid
illusion based on the
center/surround organization
of retinal ganglion
cells is incorrect.
That's a polite way of
saying it's all wrong.
A more likely theory
is the one that
assumes that area V1
cells are involved.
Retinal adaptation processes
can explain illusions
based on aftereffects,
and you've
seen quite a few of those.
And many illusions disappear
under isoluminant conditions.
And lastly, there are no viable
theories that explain illusions
based on figure/ground
relationships.
We know what they
are, but we don't
know how the brain resolves
figure and ground effects.
So that then is the end of
what I wanted to cover today.
And next time, we are going
to talk about eye movement.
And I hope that you
will enjoy that as well.